sharp uptick in the number of German
firms beginning insolvency proceedings
is Raising eyebrows in Europe's largest
economy
some 762 firms declared bankruptcy in
September that's a 34 increase from the
same period last year
and the upward trend is set to continue
this month and the next that's according
to the Hala Institute for economic
research according to their new report
by November up to 40 percent more
companies could be beginning insolvency
proceedings compared to the same period
last year
now the report blames not just a
lackluster economic Outlook but an
aberrant period during the covid-19
pandemic that's when insolvency numbers
actually fell
I asked Economist Stefan Mueller how to
interpret the new numbers and the
overall trend
yeah it's important to put those numbers
into perspective so we have seen uh
declining bankruptcy numbers for almost
20 years now and there was a particular
dip over the corona pandemic
so the increase that we see now is
indeed partly a return to normalcy but
only partly the the rise in bankruptcy
numbers are relatively strong and if it
continues we'll likely uh well have more
bankruptcies than before the pandemic so
it has to do with the economic
circumstances and uh having said this we
are still far away from a bankruptcy
wave
I want to go back many of our viewers
may not understand why did insolvencies
actually fall during the pandemic one
would think that they would rise as
times became tougher for businesses
well we have seen a lot of rescue
measures during the pandemic so for a
couple of months the bankruptcy was even
not
um obligatory even if you meet the
criteria for bankruptcy and many firms
actually just waited to see whether they
will be viable after the pandemic so
there was kind of a wait and see
mentality and the question is now
whether the rising numbers uh also
partly reflect kind of bankruptcies that
have been postponed just uh during the
pandemic all right so maybe bouncing
back after that period of fewer uh
insolvencies
um what is the biggest challenge that
businesses are facing right now looking
forward
one challenge of course arising
um energy costs but this is mostly
hitting energy intensive well industrial
firms and indirectly other firms because
of uh depressed consumer demand but
there this is not the whole story right
we have at the same time also Rising
interest rates so uh borrowing money is
getting much more costly and this is in
particular a problem for weak firms so
refinancing is much more costly than it
used to be over the last years and it's
going to be more costly in the months to
come then we see uh increasing wages uh
in particular we saw a sharp hike in the
minimum wage uh just last week it
increased by 14
and on top of this of course we are
going to go into a recession uh with
lower demand so there is a bundle of
reasons that uh well yeah can lead to a
dangerous situation here
right now in Germany there's a
discussion about capping gas prices
essentially artificially bringing Energy
prices lower how critical could this be
for the number of insolvencies we see in
the months ahead can you make any
connection between this discussion and
what we'll see with insolvencies
it's actually hard to make a connection
between those two things because the
number of energy intensive firms going
bankrupt this
relatively low at the moment we see
quite a few bankruptcies in retail for
instance this is not an energy intensive
sector so I would expect to see not a
big influence of those well energy Cost
Cuts on the bankruptcy numbers all right
that's Stefan Mueller at the Hala
Institute for economic research thank
you so much